-Our next guest is a very
talented actor and comedian.
Comedian -- he's one of
the best comedians.
He's the host of
the "WTF" podcast
and stars in the new film
"Stardust,"
which is in theaters and on
demand starting November 25th.
Here is Marc Maron.
Marc, look at you.
-How are you, man?
-You look great.
-I'm outside, Jimmy.
I'm outside.
-That's what I'm talking about.
You're outside.
All right, all right.
-All right, already.
What are we doing?
-I love that you're outside.
-...doing outside?
I got the trees here.
-I would do the same thing.
I would do the same thing.
-I'll tell you, I miss
something, though,
about being in this --
I don't know how you're
handling this,
but one of the things I used to
enjoy about doing the show
is in the dressing room
you had the nice cookies
and maybe a t-shirt.
Now are they being sent to me?
Because that's one
of the reasons --
it's not the only reason
I do it,
but am I getting the cookies?
-Of course you are.
-Thank you.
Because I don't know how this is
going to go without the cookies.
I like to be jammed on sugar
every time I talk to you
so I can keep up.
-Well, Marc, it's been a long
week for everybody.
But you --
-Oh my God, thank God!
Right?
I mean, jeez.
I thought I was going to have to
leave the country,
and that's not easy now.
I had a big plan.
But if you want to get out,
you can't. You know why?
Because, we're plague-infected
pig people
who can't behave like
responsible adults.
You can't even go
to another country.
It's like, "I'm from America,
I'd like to spend a year
in Ireland."
"Sorry, you plague-infected
pig person
who can't act like a responsible
grown-up."
"But I have my mask."
"Well, tell that to the other
pig people that live
in your country.
You plague ridden monster."
[ Laughter ]
"Look at you, you plague-
infected pig person."
[ Laughter ]
So, I'm glad that I can
stay in the country
because I would've had to, like,
you know, mail myself somewhere.
Just for a little while.
-But you got out.
You said,
"I'm not watching this.
I got to get away somewhere."
-Oh, I did, yeah, for the actual
election, I'm like,
"What's the point of maps
and numbers for three days
that aren't going to go
anywhere, but sit there
and make you go like,
'Oh, my God!
Is he going to win?'"
-Yeah.
-So, I went to up to Big Sur,
and I went to a hotel
where there was spotty wi-fi,
spotty cell coverage,
just me alone with my thoughts,
and it was nice to really
experience
the pure existential panic
and fear
without being interrupted by
televised existential
panic and fear.
It was surprising.
The small amount of information
I was getting
was enough for me to freak out
without any input whatsoever.
So, I was there looking
at the ocean,
just sitting there going like,
"Oh, man, we're in trouble, man.
This is not going well,
but it's pretty.
Look at the birds."
-Yeah.
-So a couple of sweaty nights
of panic but no TV.
And I got home right in time
yesterday to catch
what was the turning point,
which was very exciting.
And, I guess they voted out
COVID too,
no more COVID, which is nice.
That's a relief, because I was
getting tired of that.
-Next thing they
have to vote out
is quarantine sourdough bread.
-Dude, I think that's over.
I saw that kind of trickle away
within three months.
You got these like, hipster dads
and cute young moms like,
"Look at the bread I made."
But now they're just like,
"Where I bury my family?"
"I couldn't -- I --
[ Laughter ]
The bread didn't hold me back.
Enough with the bread, what do I
do with the bodies?"
-That was all fake.
[ Laughing ]
It was covering up,
yeah, something deep.
-Yeah. Oh, yeah.
Just fury.
Just like, "This will be fun.
Look, dad's making bread."
Three months later,
"Dad's a monster."
-Dad's getting a divorce.
-"Make some more bread."
"The bread's over.
Give me some candy."
-So, I take it you haven't done
any baking, then?
-Well, you know,
I do enjoy cooking.
I'm shucking my own oysters.
And that's not code.
Well, I guess it is,
'cause I'm doing that too.
But I'm actually --
[ Laughter ]
I'm actually --
-Oh, my gosh.
-I'm actually --
-Are you really?
-I buy oysters
and I shuck them.
I learned how to shuck them
for the -- you know,
I'm going to need to know
that in the future.
-Do you wear a chain glove?
-No, no, no. I watched a video.
I'm getting better at it.
But I like to eat the oysters.
I do baking.
I enjoy -- like I got it
in my head last week --
a couple weeks ago,
I'm going to make this cake.
'Cause I have the
"New York Times" cooking app,
or the Instagram
for "New York Times" cooking,
and cakes will come through.
And one day, I'm just sort of
like, "Aw, man, life sucks.
I'm going to make that cake,
and I put a lot of work into it.
Got it -- You need a Bundt pan,
and you've got to poke holes
in it to pour the butter into.
It was a complicated bit of
business,
and I screwed up the last step.
And I knew it --
-Yep.
-As I did it, like,
I screwed up the cake.
But I'm like, it's probably
still okay, I'll just --
it's going to come out
of the pan, and I turn over
the Bundt pan to take
the cake out,
and it's stuck in the Bundt pan.
So now I'm just like livid.
I'm furious, and I'm like,
[bleep] it,
I'm throwing it away.
So I start ripping the cake
with my hands.
Hot cake, with my hands,
out of the Bundt pan
and throw it in the garbage.
But I took a fistful of it.
Like, it's equivalent to maybe
a piece or two,
and just start shoving
it in my mouth,
and they're
throwing the rest away,
shoving the hot cake in my
mouth, which was terrific.
So -- But the problem was,
I got all the food shame
without the pride.
I screwed up the cake,
and was just angry at myself,
and I was eating it
by the handful, which made me
feel like a pig.
And so there was no joy.
Very little joy.
-Yeah. No.
-Just shame and fury.
But, a week later, I nailed it.
Made the cake,
and it came out perfect.
But then, the other problem is,
I was like very proud
of my cake, but I live alone.
So, now I got to figure out how
to unload the cake.
So, I'm out in the street
with my mask on.
My neighbor's cleaning his car,
I'm like, "Troy, you want cake?
How about some cake?"
And Troy's like, "Yeah."
So, I go in the house,
I bring Troy some cake,
and then I give it to him,
and that puts you
in a weird situation,
'cause two hours later
I'm kind of hanging around
outside looking for Troy, like,
"Hey, how was the cake?
Cake pretty good?"
And then he's like,
"It's a little sweet."
And I'm like,
"What the [bleep] do you want?
It was free cake."
I didn't say that part out loud.
But that's what I was thinking
about it.
-Don't judge.
You just say it was good
and you go back inside.
-But then he said as I'm
walking away, he goes,
"You should open a bakery."
So I guess this is
the announcement.
I'm opening a bakery.
-This is not true.
Before we get into your bakery,
I want to talk about
"Stardust."
Because I'm very excited
about this.
I'm very, very
excited about this.
I love David Bowie.
-Yeah.
-And this is a story -- a very
specific time in bowie's life.
-Right, this is getting --
People are going, like,
"It's a biopic."
It's not a biopic.
Yeah, it's very --
It's a -- Why am I holding
a piece of paper towel
on national television?
Because I'm outside my house!
[ Laughter ]
There's no mystery to this
anymore, Jimmy.
-No!
-I saw your couch last week.
You had to go back to the studio
because your wife was like,
"Can we not do this in the house
anymore?
Does this have to be done
in the house, Jimmy?
I can't keep the kids quiet
for an hour, Jimmy."
-"Get back to work."
Yeah, exactly right, buddy.
-I'm making a bread, Jimmy!
-Exactly right.
-But this -- I like this --
-Okay, so anyways --
-I like this because you're the
publicist for Mercury Records.
-Right. Ron Oberman was
kind of a down-and-out publicist
for Mercury Records.
And the time period,
it's before Bowie's a star.
He had a hit with
"Space Oddity,"
But no one knew whether he was a
novelty act or a one-time thing.
And he made "The Man Who
Sold the World" and it got --
People didn't know
what to do with it.
It was a dark record.
-Yeah.
-So they kind of send him
to America.
In the movie, he doesn't have
the right papers.
I'm the only guy that's
going to champion him.
The label doesn't know
what to do with it.
He's about to lose his deal,
but I think he's a genius.
So it's sort of -- My part
of the movie is him and I --
I I'm trying to get him
little gigs
to play or be on the radio
without the proper paperwork
for him to play, so we
spend a lot of time driving
in the car across country.
He sort of doesn't know
who he's going to be
or what he wants to be.
And there's all these
conversations about music
and about whether
he believes in himself.
And there's a back story
about his stepbrother
who had mental problems,
and he was worried
he was going to have
mental problems.
So it's a very small
slice of a young Bowie's life.
-I love that.
I know you love music.
So I go --
-Love it.
-Marc is perfect for this
because we always discuss music.
I know you're a giant
Stones fan.
Me as well.
We just love --
-Yeah.
-I mean, just mu--
Do you remember the first time
you heard Bowie?
-The first time I heard Bowie
I think was at
a 7th grade dance.
The song "Fame" was a big hit.
-Whew, wow.
-And I remember this because
there was a local AM deejay
named Bobby Box, and you know,
when you're a kid,
you listen to the radio
all the time
and Bobby Box was the guy.
And Bobby Box was coming to
our school to host the dance,
so we're all excited to
see Bobby Box.
Turns out,
he's basically a dwarf
and he was just like a giant
head in a strange plaid suit...
-Yep.
-And we are like,
"Oh, man, this is sad."
-That was real deejays
back then.
-Right, real guys.
But then "Fame" comes on,
and you know that part, like,
"Fame, fame, fame, fame..."?
-Yeah, John Lennon.
-Did you know -- Yeah.
I found out John Lennon was
part of that crew.
And it's always weird
when you find that out
'cause then you're listening
for the John Lennon,
for the one John Lennon "fame."
That's John!
-Yeah, or it's like this,
like, "The song isn't about him
'cause he's going,
'Is it about you?'
He's harmon--
So the song is not -- Yeah,
I love finding that stuff out.
-Do remember like Velvet --
like Lou Reed,
"Satellite of Love"?
-Yeah.
-Listen to that.
It's Bowie in the back.
Like, 'cause he produced it.
So, "uh-hoo!"
-Yes.
-It's like, that's Bowie!
You didn't know that, Jimmy.
-I didn't know that, dude.
-You didn't know it.
-You just saw that.
-And I just told it to you,
and now you're gonna know it.
-Wow!
-Now you know,
"Satellite of Love"
by Lou Reed --
listen to it,
it's on "Transformer."
-Bowie's back there.
-You keep giving me --
Oh, "Transformer,"
that's unbelievable.
No way. You just --
-Yeah.
-You keep giving me gifts.
-Go listen to it now.
-I know.
-The next thing I want is cake.
-I'll give you cake.
Oh, my God.
-Dude, stay safe, thank you
so much for coming back
to our show.
I want to show a clip.
Here is Marc Maron
in "Stardust." Take a look.
-Jeez, Tom, I have been
calling for weeks,
looking all over for you.
Did you get that album,
the David Bowie album?
Did you listen to it?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Great.
-I listened to it.
-Great, when can I get
you two to sit down
for an interview together?
-Look, I'm -- Listen,
I'm really busy right now.
-No, no, you listen, okay,
and listen good, okay?
You don't want to miss out
on this, man.
I mean, this guy's
going to be big.
-Oh, yeah? How big is big?
-Big.
-What, like Jerry Reed big
or Todd Rundgren big,
or what are we --
-No, I'm talking like Dylan big.
-[Bleep], come on.
-Serious.
This guy's like
the English Bob Dylan
with avant garde outrage
all wrapped together.
-What are you, reading this off
the [bleep] press release?
Marc Maron, everybody.
"Stardust" is in theaters
and on demand November 25th.
Marc, thank you so much again
for coming on.
It's always a pleasure, buddy.
-Thank you for having me.
It was the easiest
"Tonight Show,"
I did my own hair and makeup,
wore my own --
-I'll get you those cookies.
I promise.
-Thank you, I'm counting on it.